Transcriber: Yasmeen Elsayed
المدقّق: marshall8 mathers88
طيب يعطيكم العافية
الفصل الماضي مع ضغط الشغل
لقيت حالي في وضع شوية صعب
كانت الساعة ثنتين بالليل
وكان في عندي امتحانين اليوم اللي بعده
لازم الصباح أكون سلمت
الامتحانين وطبعت الأسئلة
وكان في عندي توقف بتدفق
الأفكار مش قادر أطلع بأفكار لأسئلة
قد ما حاولت الاسئلة مش قادرة تطلع معي
لأن الواحد لما يكون في وضع
ضعف. في نقطة ضعف
دائما الشيطان بيجي يوسوس له
وانا شيطاني وقتها جاني وقالي ليش
ما تستخدم “شات جي بي تي”
إذا الطلاب يستخدموه عشان يجاوبوا
على الأسئلة الي انت بتكتبها
انت كمان ممكن تستخدم “شات جي بي تي”
عشان يعطيك أسئلة تعطيها للطلاب
الان إذا كنت متابع
إذا ما كنت سامع “بشات جي بي تي”
المفروض انه زميلنا من المحاضرة اللي قبل
اعطاك فكرة على ايش “شات جي بي تي”
ممكن يسوي في مجال السينما
وممكن تتخيل نفس الشي على الأشياء الثانية
بالنسبة لي كشخص في مجال الحاسوب
ممكن أنا أعمل
نقاش مع “شات جي بي تي” عن كود
أوريه كود هو عمره ما شافه من قبل وأسأله ان
يشرح لي هذا الكود ممكن أتأمر عليه وأقول له
“أشرح لي باختصار. أشرح لي بالتفصيل. أشرح
لي بشكل هزلي بشكل كوميدي” أو غيره
بشكل عام عنده قدرة قوية جدا
أنه يجري معي هذا الحوار
فمثلا هنا شرحه بشكل جيد
مع إن أنا حاط له خطأ بهذا الكود
فما أثر على قدرته أن يشرح
أيش هذا البرنامج بيسوي
وبعد ما شرح لي سألته
قلت له طيب في خطأ في هذا البرنامج؟
قال نعم في خطأ في هذا البرنامج
حدد لي أياه وحكى لي وين الخطأ
وكيف يمكنني أن أصلحه
الآن
هذا شيء غير مسبوق بالنسبة لنا
نحن في علوم الحاسوب
أن يكون قادر أن يدير هذا الحوار
عن كود هو ما شافه قبل
شيء غير مسبوق
وممكن أن تقيس هذا على
جميع المجالات  الثانية
وتعرف قد ايش “شات جي بي تي” بيمثل
ذروة الذكاء الاصطناعي وتطبيقاته
في المجالات اللغوية
المهم أنه إذا أنت جديد على “شات جي بي تي”
كمان تعرف إن قدرته على
إجراء الحوار حول هذا الكود
ما كان نابع من فهمه لهذا الكود
فهو مع أنه شرحه بشكل جيد هذا
مش معناه أنه فهمه
هو كل الذي صار أنه ولّد بشكل جيد
كلمات احتمالية إن تكون هي
الكلمات التي أنا أبحث عنها
بناء على الكود اللي أنا كتبته عالية
بناء على ايش؟ بناء على
أمثلة كثيرة لا كود ولا أسئلة ثانية
هو كان شايفها من قبل
فالان الفكرة أنه هو صحيح يقدر أن
يدير الحوار به بشكل ممتاز جدا
يقدر يجاوب أسئلة معقدة جدا، ولكن في نفس
الوقت لا يقدر يجاوب أسئلة جدا بسيطة
بالنسبة لنا لأن قدرته ليس
لها علاقة بالتحليل المنطقي
وإنما قدرته بناء على
الأمثلة اللي هو شافها قبل
فسؤال بسيط جدا مثل “أيهما أثقل
كيلو الحديد أم كيلو القطن”
بيفشل فيه بشكل ذريع
المفروض أن يقول لك كيلو
من أي مادة هي نفس الشيء
بس هو بيحكيلك كيلو الحديد
أثقل من كيلو القطن
لأن هو ما بيحلل تحليل منطقي
وإنما بناء على انه شاف أمثلة قبل
فلو أخذنا الشي هذا شوية زيادة وواديناه
على شيء هو ليس متدرب عليه كثير
زي مثلا الألغاز الشعبية التي عندنا بالأردن
فتتوقع أن لأنه ما شاف زيها كثير أنه
كمان ما يقدر يجاوبك بشكل كويس
فلو سألته سؤال ذي هذا
كان يسألني جدي زمان وأنا صغير “خيار
اسمه؟ الله لا يهديك على اسمه؟ ايش اسمه؟”
ما في أي شيء في السؤال لأن السؤال
يقول لك خيار اسمه يعني اسمه خيار
بس هو شو بيقول
يقول “لا يوجد خيار يسمى “الله لا يهديك”
وهو اسم غير لائق ومهين عند استخدامه
لأي شخص أو كائن آخر
يرجى تجنب استخدام الألفاظ المسيئة
التي قد تسيء للأخرين
والحرص على استخدام أسماء لائقة”
المهم، “شات جي بي تي” هذا الذي لا يعرف
يجاوب أسئلة بسيطة مثل هذه
وبنفس الوقت بيقدر يجاوب أسئلة صعبة جدا
الشيطان حكى لي استخدمه ربما
يساعدك بأنك تكتب امتحان
فجربت حظي معه وطلبت منه
سؤال الامتحان الأول
ولم يكن حظ جيد
أعطاني سؤال مش بالمستوى لي أنا بدي أياه
طلبت منه مرة ثانية
عدلت بالوصف يمكن يعطيني
السؤال زي ما أنا بدي أياه
ما أعطاني بالشكل الي أنا بدي أياه
لقيت حالي داخل معه بحوار
على أنه أيش معنى “صعب”
أيش معنى “سهل” سهل لمين. صعب لمين.
لقيت حالي بضيع وقتي
تركته ورحت على الامتحان الثاني
يمكن يقدر أنه يعطيني شيء أفضل
هناك نفس الشيء مخيب للأمال
اقترح عليا سؤال مش زي ما أنا بدي أياه
وجوابه غلط
فدخلت معه كمان بنقاش ليش هو غلط.
كيف لازم يكون الجواب
لقيت حالي برضو أضيع وقتي فتركته
وبديت اشتغل على الامتحان لحالي
الآن، اللي صار معي في الأيام اللي بعدها
هو أنه ذهني انشغل بسؤال
إنه صحيح “شات جي بي تي” حاليا
لا يجاوب كثير من الأسئلة السهلة بشكل كويس
وما يقدر يفيدني كثير الآن
في إني أنا أكتب امتحان
كان مخيب للأمال
لكن المتوقع أنه خلال الأيام الجاية
أو السنوات الجاية
أنه راح يكون قدرته أعلى
بكثير من قدرته الحالية
متوقع جدا أنه يستطيع أن يكتب
أسئلة امتحانات ممتازة
إنه يستطيع يجاوب على أسئلة الامتحانات
إنه يتطلع على حلول الطلاب
ويطلع الأخطاء اللي فيها
يعطي تغذية راجعة للطلاب
إنه يعمل تلخيصات لمقالات، تلخيصات
لدروس أو أي شيء من هذا النوع
فالآن، إذا كان “شات جي بي تي”
خلال الفترة القادمة صار ممتاز جدا
بكل هذه الأشياء اللي أنا فعليا
تأخذ أغلب وقتي كمدرس
أنا دوري كمدرس أيش صار؟
طبعا مباشرة بيجي الرد “لا أنا كمدرس
مش فقط ناقل للمعلومة”
“أنا مربي وتربية قبل التعليم”
طبعا هذا الرد لي مباشرة أنا إمكانية
الدفاع اللي عندي ستقول
“طبعا أنا لست فقط ناقل للعلومة”
ولكن بالمقابل ممكن أجي أقول طيب
فممكن استبدالك “بشات جي بي تي”
في مجال نقل المعلومة وبمربي
لأن هذا سؤال مرعب بالنسبة لي
أنا كمدرس إن أكون على المحك
إنه فعليا أنا ممكن
استبدالي بعامل اجتماعي،
أو مستشار أو مربي زائد
“شات جي بي تي”
لأنه بيحط قيمة الشيء اللي
أنا بعمله على المحك
لأن سؤال الاستبدال
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستبدل وظيفة ما
سؤال من أربعين خمسين سنة دائما مطروح
اللي أنا كنت بتأمله إن وظيفتي
مختلفة عن هذه الوظائف
هذه الوظائف فيها شيء ميكانيكي
فيها شيء ممكن أنك أنت تعمله بخطوات
فلذلك ممكن أن المكينة ستستبدلك
أما أنا وظيفتي يعني أعظم وأسمى من ذلك
صعب إنه ذكاء اصطناعي أنه يعملها
لأن في شيء خطر على بالي
وقتها خلاني شوية أحس
أن الخطر مش كبير مقارنة
واللي هي كالتالي
إن خلال الفترة الماضية
كان في انفجار كبير في
الكورسات للتعليم عن بعد
جودتها عالية ومن مدرسين
ممتازين جدا
ولكن هي عن بعد
في نفس الوقت في مقاومة كبيرة من كثير من
الطلاب وكثير من الأهالي للتعلم عن بعد
يعني هم بدهم تدريس عن قرب
فإذا كان في مقاومة إنك تكون بعيد عن المدرس
فمن باب أولى يكون في مقاومة كمان
أن يستغني تماما الإنسان
عن المدرس ويستبدله بآلة
هل هذا شيء مطمئن؟
لكن السؤال هو ليش؟
هل هناك شيء خاص فيا كمدرس إنسان
غير موجود في الآلة
بحيث أن التعليم عن بعد
بيصير أسوأ
أو إذا لم يعد هناك إنسان
في المجال فبيصير أسوأ
هذا السؤال الذي أنا كنت أفكر فيه
في طالب سألني سؤال
قالي لي “دكتور، كيف ممكن يأثر
“شات جي بي تي” الآن على مجال البرمجة؟”
وانا أتناقش معه سألته
سؤالك هذا أنت سألته  “لشات جي بي تي“؟
قالي اه سألته “لشات جي بي تي”
وجاوبك؟ قالي جاوبني جواب ممتاز كمان
بس حابب أعرف رأيك إنت
فكان من جوابه مبين
أنه ما بيدور فقط عن معلومة
لكن بدور على ثنائي معلومة زائد إنسان معين
هو اللي يحكي هذه المعلومة
كان بيدور على هذا الشيء
في جامعة
جامعة “فاندربيلت”
جامعة معروفة
صار فيها حادث إطلاق نار في جامعة جنبها
والإداريين اللي في الجامعة
أرسلوا رسالة للطلاب
رسالة مواساة زائد توعية
بخصوص حادث إطلاق النار
اللي كتب الرسالة كتبها
باستخدام “شات جي بي تي”
الأن لما عرف الطلاب إن هذه الرسالة
كاتبها “شات جي بي تي”
يعني موظف ما كتبها بيده
ثارت ضجة كبيرة وصارت لجان
تحقيق وصار في استقالات
الآن الغضب لم يكن من الطلاب
على محتوى الرسالة
أنه والله ما كان محتوى
جيد أو كان محتوى خطأ
الغضب كان من أنه اللي ولّد المحتوى
ما كان إنسان وإنما كان آلة
يعني يبدو أن هذا الثنائي بتاع إنه في محتوى
والمحتوى صادر عن إنسان مؤثر بشكل ما
وهذا بيخليني أشعر شوية بالارتياح
أن في ميزة لكوني إنسان يعني
يبدو أنه ما من دور دائما
فقط عن معلومة ولا إنما كمان
معلومة وفي معها إنسان
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
“ولو جعلْنَهُ مَلَكًا لَجَعلْنَهُ رجُلًا
وَلَلَبَسْنَا عَلَيْهِم ما يَلْبِسُون”
يعني الرسول المعلم مقصود منه أن يكون إنسان
لأنه يعلم ناس
ولو ما كان إنسان يعني لو كان ملك
لجعلناه يظهر وكأنه رجل
لأنه مرة ثانية يبدو أنه هذه الثنائية بين
كون المعلومة صادرة من إنسان في إلها أثر
لأن التعلم مش بس معلومة
وإنما في شيء له علاقة بتجسيد
معنى الشيء اللي أنت تتعلمه
فأنا كمدرس للبرمجة بجسد معنى
إنك تكون مبرمج مسؤول
أو مبرمج دائم التعلم
أو مبرمج حذر أو غير ذلك
الآن هذه الأشياء كلية الآلة ممكن
تحكيها للمتعلم وتقول له
هكذا يمكن أن تكون مبرمج حذر
هكذا يمكن أن تكون مبرمج مسؤول
هذه الخطوات التي يجب أن تتبعها
لأن هذا مختلف تماما عن لما أنا أعيش مع
الطالب في دائرة من أن هو يكون معي
وأنا بشوف السؤال، بقسمه الأجزاء
بعدين كل جزء ببرمجه
بهيئة معينة وبكيفية معينة
بطرح أسئلة بشكل معين عن
صحة سؤالي وبعدين كيف بصححه
الآن هذه الدائرة لما يعيشها معى
ثلاث أربع مرات في المحاضرة
وبعدين عشرات المرات خلال الفصل
يستطيع أنه يتقمص شخصية المبرمج
بشكل ضمني
أنا ما بحكيله إياها
“واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة”
بينما الآلة بتقدر تحكيله إياها
ولكن الأن بعد ما شافها
هو ممكن يقدر يتخيل حاله
ذاك الإنسان اللي بيعمل هذا الشيء
الآن، هذا طبعا مريح جدا بالنسبة لي
أنه أنا أحس أنه بس لأني إنسان
فيه عندي ميزة عن الآلة
يعني لو الألة عملت شيء
وأنا عملت نفس الشيء بالضبط
بس لأني أنا إنسان تعطيني أجر عليه
أشي مريح بالنسبة إلي أنا كإنسان
ممكن أجر منه سلسلة
من الأشياء اللي أنا أحكي عنها زي هيك
فمثلا أنا كإنسان عندي شجاعة
الآلة ما في عندها أصلا مفهوم الشجاعة
عندي قدرة إني أنا أخذ رأي
ووقف على صف ما زي الألة، بس أقول
هناك رأيان والرأي الأول حجته كذا
والرأي الثاني حجته كذا
لا، أنا أخذ رأي وبدافع عن هذا الرأي
مثلا عندي الشجاعة إني
قواعد “تيد” تحكيني ما تحط
نقاط تقسيم على الشاشة
وبخط نقاط تقسيم على الشاشة
وبتحمل مسؤولية القرار اللي أنا أخذه
الآن هذا قرار صحيح ولا مش صحيح
مش هذا اللي على المحك
اللي على المحك إن في فرق كبير لما
إنك انت تعيش مع شخص يتبنى رأي
وفي شد وجذب حول هذا الرأي
مقارنة بأنك تعرف بوجود رأي ما
فلما أنا أجي أحكي للطلاب
أن هذه الخاصية في البرمجة
أفضل أنك انت تستخدمها
مقابل هذه الخاصية في البرمجة
أو إنك تبرمج هيك أحسن منك تبرمج هيك
وأبني مسار كامل بناء على هذا
الرأي وهو عارف أن في رأي أخر
مختلف تماما لأن الشد والجذب اللي بيصير
بناء على تحمل لجانب من الجانبين
هو اللي بيحصل التعلم مش مجرد
المعرفة. بوجود أراء مختلفة
بدي أختم بمثال
على شيء أزعم أنه
صعب إن ألة إنها تعمله
وهو له علاقة بكوني مدرس في الميدان
بلاحظ وبتعامل مع مدرسين بشر
كمان عندي في الميدان
عندنا في اختبارات البرمجة نقيس هل الطالب
يستطيع أن يكتب برامج
وهل الطالب يستطيع أن يقرأ برامج
الآن في مدرسين خلال الخمس عشرة
سنة الماضية لاحظوا من التعامل مع الطلاب
إنه في بعض الطلاب عندهم القدرة
إنه يفهم أجزاء البرنامج
بس ما يقدر يشوف الصورة كاملة
فطلعوا بطريقة للقياس عشان نفرق
بين هذين النوعين من الطلاب
الطالب الي لما يتطلع على الكود يفهم فكرته
والثاني لما يطلع على الكود يفهم أجزاؤه
سموهم أسئلة “أشرح بلغة انجليزية بسيطة”
هذه الأسئلة تعطيه الكود ويطلب منه أن
يشرح بالمختصر بالإنجليزي
ايش هذا البرنامج يعمل
إذا استخدم كلمات قليلة جدا
بتعبر عن الهدف فهو فاهم الفكرة
إذا استخدم تفاصيل طويلة
وصار يقولك “بيعمل هيك وهيك وهيك،
والسطر الأول كذا وكذا”
فهو شايف الصورة الكاملة
الآن، أسئلة “أشرح بلغة انجليزي بسيطة” هذه
نتجت عن تفاعل بين الدكاترة وملاحظاتهم
أنا كمدرس أستخدمها أو استخدمتها مدة
لاحظت أنه في كثير من الطلاب
عنده مشكلة بالتعبير مش مشكلة بالفهم
فلما يكون عنده سؤال
“أشرح بلغة انجليزية بسيطة”
هو يجاوبه غلط مش لأنه
مش فاهم الصورة العامة
وإنما لأنه عنده مشكلة
بالتعبير عن الصورة العامة
لأن هذه الملاحظة جرتني إلى سنة كاملة
من البحث عن طريقة
ممكن أفرق فيها بين الطالب اللي
فهم الصورة العامة واللي فهم الأجزاء
ما تكون تعتمد على التعبير وإنما
تعتمد فقط على فهمه للبرنامج .
هذا كان خلاله كمية كبيرة من الفحص اللي
بعملها لامتحانات الطلاب
وللتحليل والمناقشة مع دكاترة
زائد مقابلات مع الطلاب
أقعد معه وأسأل خطوة خطوة “أنت ليش
عملت هيك  وليش عملت هيك وليش عملت هيك”
عبال ما طلعت بطريقة فعلا أنا الان
استخدمها في الامتحانات
عشان أفرق بين هذين النوعين
من القدرات في القراءة
أنا أدعي إنه هذا لا يمكن الآلة أنها تعمله
لأن ملاحظتها محصورة
بما طلب منها إنها تلاحظه
وما عندها القدرة أن تولد سؤال خارج نطاق
الأسئلة اللي يفترض أنها تولد فيه
بينما اللي صار معي هنا أنا
لاحظت تولد عندي سؤال جديد
حطيت لحالي هدف أن أنا
بدي الاقي جواب هذا السؤال
وساعدني فيه مجموعة ثانية من
الدكاترة اللي عندهم نفس الملاحظة
فطلع معي هذا النوع من الأسئلة
بنحكي عن الامتحانات ممكن تسألوني عن
الامتحانين اللي كنت بحاول أن أكتبهم
بدي أوريكم سؤال كتبته الساعة أربعة
بالليل بعد ما طلع معي السؤال
السؤال كان هذا
أن يرسم فم أفعى مفتوحة
لأن هذا السؤال كيف طلع
طلع نتيجة حالتي الشعورية هذا اليوم
قد أيش أنا عندي رغبة أني أطلع بسؤال
جديد مختلف عن اللي كان قبل
أنا أيش قناعتي عن كيف لازم نقيس فهم الطلاب
أيش قناعتي عن أيش المهم
عن صيغة الأسئلة الكويسة
قد أيش أعرف أنا عن الطلاب
إنهم كيف كان مستواهم بأسئلة سابقة
أيش نوع الأمثلة اللي شافوها
الدكاترة الثانين أيش
نوع الأسئلة اللي يحبونها
لأن هذا الخليط كله أنتج سؤال زي هيك
فأنا كمان أدعي أنه يستحيل على الآلة
إنها تصدر سؤال مثله إلا لو
كل هذه الأشياء المتراكبة
المعقدة كانت عند إنسان
ولّد سؤال مثل هذا السؤال
صار مثال ممكن الآلة تولد زيه
ولكن ابتداءً تطلع بزيه؟
ما أظن
هذا كله كلام مريح وأنا مبسوط أنه أشعر أنه
في أشياء كثيرة بس لأني أنا إنسان
تعطيني أجر على الآلة وهيك
الآلة صعب إنها تبدلني
لكن في نفس الوقت
الكلام هذا كله له معنى
وهو أنه إذا كنت أنا ما بدي
أُستبدل من قبل الآلة
فلازم أركز على الجهة اللي
أنا أحسن من الآلة فيها
واللي هي الجانب الإنساني
اللي حكيت عنه قبل شوية
ولكن أغلب وقتي مش زي هيك
أنا أغلب وقتي كمدرس أكتب أسئلة
وبصحح واجبات
وبجاوب على أسئلة الطلاب
هذه كلها هي الأشياء السهلة
اللي الآلة ممكن إنها تعملها
الجانب الإنساني الذي يتطلب ملاحظة وبحث
وتجريب وتجسيد مثال وشجاعة وآراء وكذا
هذا الجانب كلياته هو الجانب الأصعب
في مهنتي واللي بيأخذ الوقت الأقل مني
إذا كنت أنا ما بدي أن أُستبدل من الآلة
فهذا الجانب اللي أنا لازم أركز عليه
وهذا الجانب هو الأصعب في مهنتي
لذلك أتوقع إنه في المستقبل
مهنتي ما راح تكون أسهل
راح تكون أصعب
يعطيكم العافية